six years ago I got an invitation to go
down a bobsleigh track and I was too
scared and I turned it down but since
then these folks have been helping run
this Channel and they got me over my
fear of roller coasters so thank you for
that
this is Chris spring world-class bobsley
athlete and this is the Whistler sliding
Center in Canada so for the season
finale for the Christmas special we
brought the entire team out here to
Canada and we're going to throw
ourselves down above slate track
which includes by the way the camera
team
[Music]
all right
hello hello
how's it going
well welcome to the sledding Center my
name is Philip I'm gonna be showing you
a few things before we go so follow me
and we can get started
you're going to go down the fastest
deepest strike in the world so on
average speed for a track is 135k an
hour here top speed is 155 from the top
so big jump we need to regrum the track
by hand believe it or not because of the
speed so that's what the guys are doing
so uh a little warning about the ride uh
you might not like it
[Laughter]
there's nothing we can do about it okay
yeah once you start that's that's it
you're ready nothing like you expect uh
you're gonna post three to four G forces
so you're gonna wait three to four times
your weight those are positive G's means
it's like pressure on you there's no
negative G's the negative G's that's why
you're experiencing a roller coaster
when your stomach goes up you know drop
upside down we don't have that it's not
scary the other one they start from the
top they go up to 155k five to six G's
on the back that's why they only go for
three runs a day or two never more after
three they really can't take it anymore
so three minutes or two minutes of
training per day wow because after that
you feel I'm really tired and you can't
take it anymore
uh so if you have any heart condition
any and neck back injury pregnant
osteoporosis please don't go we're
really serious about that yeah okay we
have one crew member who has a will not
be going for medical reasons so that's
uh okay I didn't know if you wanted to
mention that on camera or not I was just
gonna say I was just saying medical
reasons that's that's fine
so when there's a cut like the one on a
competition sleds the nose can move the
nose is articulated
and when the nose can move like that the
slit can go harder in a corner and the
back follows and they can get more speed
the downside is they can go too high on
the cash so they they're easy to crash
the other one is called a plank set
there's no Cuts uh the slower uh
smoother safer but because this slower
we don't use them with the public we're
going to use a real one oh wow okay so
we're going in the less safe mode yes
okay we're going we're going with the
faster ones
I call them the more fun one all right
uh we're gonna start you from corner
seven not the top uh there's different
reasons for that so the top it's uh it's
hell the main reason we don't start from
the top is because of this corner you
see that fake straight line this is the
hardest Corner in the world by far the
athlete during the 2010 Olympic named it
50 50. we thought that was a funny name
so we kept it 50 50 what
uh 50 chance to go through it properly
on your wireless oh wow over 50 chance
of yeah okay yeah cool so it's not going
full speed through that
so this is what could happen uh if
you're in a crash the sled is going to
slide on its side or upside down all the
way to the bottom we have a staff
waiting with some hooks at the bottom in
case of a crash and then the stuff is
going to stop you it's going to help you
to exit the sled and the track you're
gonna have a good story for tonight okay
does it happen often
uh
uh no
I did not believe you okay all right
that's it ready to go ready ready let's
drive to the top
[Music]
ready for some bobsled we are we are
sled number one uh sled number two is
behind the various cameras here in a
minute so uh yeah I'm my nerves haven't
kicked in yet have they for you long ago
yeah they did they've dissipated a bit
but they'll come back I remember it
um honestly didn't realize it didn't
have a back for realsies
yeah no back door until this morning
there's a little bit of a lip you'll be
fine just just hold on yeah you'll be
surprised how much uh the pressure will
squish you into place okay and not allow
you to fall out the back so how long
have you been doing this uh this is my
16th year as a bobsledder wow we did the
research you most decorated Olympian
bobsled most decorated Canadian Olympian
houses well I don't know about that but
I've definitely we've been to four
Olympic games which is uh
one less than
one other Olympics yeah but we couldn't
get him to get to come here so you have
me wait we're both I'm trying to be not
too awkward you're trying to be nice and
Canadian you're self-deprecating here
and all right we're in good hands then
like this is this is
a heck of a run I'm just looking at that
that doesn't look that steep that it's a
long way down but I might I might start
doing Pride before a fall here because I
did you're nodding I've seen the track
mate okay this is the thing they've seen
it they've recorded I haven't this is
all I've seen
um right here it doesn't look too steep
but once we get going
um by Corner 11 12 13 it really starts
picking up and you'll start to feel that
pressure that I was talking about how
long is the Run gonna be around 40
seconds
sounds quick but it does I'll let you
know when we get down how are you
feeling about it
yeah I feel like the first few Corners
are going to be okay and we'll probably
get cocky and then
our heads will start doing this
especially if you don't know which way
the corners go I'm not sure how much you
studied the track or not
in hindsight that would have been a
really good idea Your Instinct will kick
in when things do start you know
rattling around quite a bit and you'll
end up yeah kind of resorting to that
Turtle type shape that you'll make how
much steering is involvement because we
got told basically
skeleton goes down on its own more or
less luge really really difficult
bobsleigh you have to know your line you
have to come through it's not like it's
not like if you didn't steer it would
just go slow if you didn't steer it
would
exactly yeah we would be on our heads
right
um and how much of on our heads is there
action because I saw these little like
guardy things up here yeah they uh they
put these in for the for the public ride
here yeah we have these extra little
humps it's mainly just a visual to make
you feel that you're more safe that's
really what I wanted to do yeah great
thanks man you'll be on your head for
sure we are on our heads how are the
folks behind the cameras feeling you all
okay
Jamie how are you feeling
that was a lie maybe maybe I'm exerting
this confidence yeah yeah so we're gonna
walk down into Corner seven this is the
first curve that we're going to be
entering today and we'll talk a little
bit about the science and the physics
behind what we're trying to do how we're
manipulating the sled in curve seven
all right let's go but what's unique
about this curve is that it is laid back
quite a lot more than most Corners in
the world so when you say laid back like
the angle yeah it's uh it's come up a
little bit closer here and see if we can
see the track is kind of
we call it an open curve so there isn't
much
um of like an overhang of the roof it's
not like cupped like this and when it's
open like this the pressure
is
a lot more difficult to feel in your
hands because the sled we always talk
about
if we did nothing what would happen to
the sled and then we're trying to
manipulate the sled to be on the perfect
blind from there how do you learn that
feeling like how because you can't you
can't like go down at half speed that
doesn't make sense the first time you
take the the controls
how do you know what to do
yeah it's very difficult to teach
and we give we give new drivers we give
them all this information and we hope
that okay they understand what we're
talking about all right
instinctive is it a lot of it is it is
yeah and a lot of it is that feeling
that I talk about we feel about the
pressure I feel it in in my stomach I
feel it in my butt in the amount of
pressure that's that's in my body and so
I kind of steer using that feeling as
well
all right should we do it yeah let's go
[Music]
so I'm in first are you gonna stand here
for a sec yep
what are you gonna be doing okay go
inside yep
have a seat okay now you're nervous
here I should have done this six years
ago
okay
cool
how are you feeling back there
it feels very exposed doesn't it yeah
time when I get in my bum is really
close to your face all right there's
nothing we can do about that yeah
all right okay
yeah it's comfortable isn't it yeah I'm
happy with this
I'm worried about like keeping my back
straight and I'm not sure what counts as
leaning back up okay that's leaning back
so I just hit guy in the head sorry
about that
let's do it
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
that's interesting
oh that was brilliant I loved it
that was so good
how are we doing gang thank you Chris we
survived thank you so much didn't fall
out the back right you're happy thank
you so much yeah my pleasure all right
this is what I love right here seeing
the smiles
this is great oh my God recruit it's
your turn yeah off you go guys how you
feeling how you feeling
I'm out a few words I'm not a few words
foreign
[Music]
foreign